this show is brought to you by
betterhelp now look I know I joke that
some anxiety is good and I stand by that
hot take but it can it can it can tell
us to get you know out of a bad
situation out of a bad relationship to
solve a problem we've been ignoring but
chronic worry is no bueno I'm bilingual
now that's no good okay I I have that
every look every Monday at two o'clock I
talked to Barbara all right I puke up
all my worries she's like hey worry is a
negative contribution to your future
self and worry doesn't work if anything
feel guilt because that means you're
probably standing up for yourself
and I'm like damn Barbara that's a
banger she helps me get out of my inner
child and into my adult child and yells
at me to journal
which is very annoying but then I do it
and I feel better
and I'm like bitch Barbara I wish I
could see you every day I wish you could
coach me every day out of my gross
intrusive thoughts that no longer serve
me going to therapy it's like it's like
having the smartest mom on the planet
tell you what to do in a way that makes
it your idea it's the best therapy gets
you out of your negative thought cycles
and helps you find some mental and
emotional peace do it for you and all
the people around you that you love if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist at any time
I'll charge get a break from your
thoughts with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com Whitney today to get 10
off your first month that's
helphelp.com
Whitney betterhelp.com
Whitney do it for us
you know what it is when you get
pregnant your hair did Jazzy have this
yeah where your hair in the front they
just turn into like Italian pubes yeah
yeah 100 because your entire
well here we'll talk about on the
podcast but I'm going bald like in a
little patches it's all normal she lost
hair she lost some hair too yeah but I
but you're just talking about your
producer in the middle
dude when you get pregnant you do turn
into Homer Simpson yeah like I've got a
belly
it's like a nightmare and then you get
horny yeah oh for sure you're just like
FIFA
make me come this is like awful
uh let me ask do we have the right thing
up for you yeah that was perfect I am
gonna get the black face spray to put on
myself do it okay you can start the show
go ahead hello hello
hi I'm Whit I'm Whitney's son
I'm Whitney's unborn son this is what
this is what Whitney's child will look
like
um this is who it'll be I uh
I'm lit right now lit wow I have a big
head you better hope your baby doesn't
have a big head you know what I just
watched though okay because the big
thing is vaginal or cesarean what kind
do you want to have one giant butthole
slash vagina right or do you want a
happy face belly I mean listen my jazz
went through two veggies you know but I
mean she like blew her pussy off like it
like just went through two badges as if
she had to get a new one went through
that one like I felt something hit my
foot when my second daughter was born I
was like what is that the doctor's like
that's her vagina it's on your shoelace
but I watched a video that when they
they come out their heads are like
Pangea plates you know what I mean and
so it's not that the vagina gets as big
as their head it's that their head does
shrink right and they have a little
conehead for the first couple days
bonehead first couple days and that's
why it's extremely important
fontanelle's there called your baby's
heads the skull will not be formed fully
formed for weeks after the baby's born
so you cannot you know like if you you
press down on its head they'll tell you
all that you cannot you'll like can push
it in its brain because its head isn't
because it can't have a fully formed
skull because how is it going to get
through yeah a vagina I mean the woman
has to have a really big pussy okay
but so because but I'm more worried
about the shoulders than the head God if
the shoulders okay I'm saying well I I
think feel fair to yes I think um I have
questions for you yes I think um you
know she it all depends too how the baby
you know as it breached what which ways
it's coming out like who knows I mean
sometimes Jazz was this close to like
having to get a C-section anyway because
my second daughter was like upside down
yeah so like you'll just see maybe she
should stop Soul cycling yeah 20 minutes
before giving birth yeah she's fucking
on the spin bike all day maybe that's
what happened to her vagina my kid's
head looks like a bike seat got a
triangle head
it is amazing how much she exercised
through and after she put off the baby
weight she go like you know for her like
it was gone like very quickly I mean
she's yeah you're the enemy an enemy to
women yes all women yes she um and then
you know I put on I got like really
heavy with when she didn't I gained like
40 pounds it was like it was literally I
couldn't even stop it I wasn't even like
I was eating more I'm sure but like I it
was like nature was putting weight dad
on me because I think that there is
something I don't know if it's
scientifically proven or not there is
something where it's like we're in this
together even though I'm not going
through litter I'm going through
literally nothing yeah you're going
through all the pain and everything but
I think nature is like well at least
let's make him fat again so he's not as
kind of um presentable to other women so
he'll stay and raise his baby like that
that's right right sure and they'll say
like you'll notice your baby like my
daughters for the both of them for the
first week looked exactly like my dad
like just say you don't kill them yeah
like my literally my beautiful daughter
orders look like a man who's known as
Tampa Tony so it wasn't great
did you give birth in L.A because that's
when they transitioned two days
yeah you're pregnant because I was like
this whole time I throw Whitney with
strands well men can get pregnant
wow and so and yes and so but but I
think that's also from nature is the
baby a lot of times looks like the
father because Nature has all these
built-in things that are like do not
leave don't leave the baby especially in
these first couple of weeks so it's like
because you'll think a man will think is
that even my kid and they'll make it
Nature has these things where it's like
most times it looks like the dad and
you're like right away and then it
changes once again like around a year
right like my daughter like I have my my
my toe next to my big toe is crossed
over like this like just a disgusting
like witched web foot and so the toes
when my daughter was born her toes were
crossed over as if to say nature was
like that is your baby like because
they're not crossed over anymore imagine
how dumb we used to be that we'd be
confused or how many partners a woman
used to have oh yeah yeah no or like it
used to be like back in the day like if
you you you know some of the pregnancy
symptoms you were going through they
were like I'm gonna burn you I'm gonna
burn you at the stake because your hair
started to fall out because you're
pregnant because the hormonal imbalance
because like your hair is falling out
you must have cheated on your husband
burned you yeah but also um uh who was
it maybe Dr Drew is saying that uh
because I was like what's up with being
horny when you're pregnant wouldn't you
not want to have sex or infection it
doesn't make any sense and he's like oh
it's so that you bond with the father
and have someone around and start well
you gotta understand too like again I'm
only knowing this as a father like
Jasmine went through it all but like one
thing I learned from going through this
twice is like your entire body right now
for the next nine months it is solely
one thousand percent yeah only trying to
keep the baby alive it only cares about
you yeah because you're keeping that
baby alive so you'll lose hair you'll
get your fingers and uh you don't need
your fingers and your and your toes so
that's why you'll get coldness in the
extremities or your arms or legs will
get cold because it's like blood flow to
the baby if something happened to you
right now like your heart rate start to
go low they would pump everything to
that fucking baby we're supposed to die
in childbirth nature prefers it yes like
the baby wants to take it I mean they
strip uh cells from your brain and if
you and this is the thing because a lot
of people are getting surrogates now and
I'm like oh but what if they don't eat
healthy or what if and doctor's like it
doesn't matter right because if they eat
McDonald's every day the baby will just
take the nutrients from the bones and
then the mom will get osteoporosis dude
look look at you you can have AIDS and
your baby won't get AIDS you know
because you don't tell me because your
body's just like I'm not going to give
this baby aids if this if this bitch
wants to get AIDS think about it our
life expectancy used to be 25 30. so
it's like if you're a woman getting
pregnant you you're disposable yeah
you're disposable and it and it's one of
those things where you know you're into
it's true and you guys can have kids so
you're 85. yeah and this is a nightmare
well I mean our reproductive system is
designed to spread and your reproductive
system is designed to catch so every the
way the vagina and it's curved is to
gravity hits the sperm in and the way
mine
know that yours is to scoop out the
semen of the competitor right that well
the ridge I guess it is I guess it could
be yeah but my but on the streets you
know a seed spreader ignore the seed
catcher I love my favorite thing about
Chris is I'm always surprised at how
smart you are and then you're undermined
by like one word every day
you'll just yeah I do that too I get got
yeah like one like students brother yeah
yeah or like I was I was I was like
almost like giving like a borderline
dissertation to like my friends and
family about like the ancient Greeks and
I was and and I had all the right facts
and I was saying all the right things
but I was calling I was calling Plato
Pluto
for like I was like you know Pluto said
Pluto said in the democracy and then
they were just listening to me and then
Jasmine was like you know it's Play-Doh
you keep saying Pluto you imbecile
that's the one thing everybody else
knows the one thing you don't know yeah
yeah yeah I could do everything else but
not because I hate it when you're like
no I'm smarter than you yeah I know this
shit I'm not I'm just not I'm not
preoccupied in the weeds yeah yeah but
how it's pronounced yeah I'm doing the
other shit but um yeah look at you look
in your nipples hard now my baby is that
what it is probably one's usually hard
and one's not hard body is just so pitch
black yeah oh yeah well they get really
dark really fast okay and they didn't
paint them black
I'm going black face press it's amazing
to just see like all the stuff that
starts happening right like that's so
that the baby can find the nipple yeah
also one thing you'll notice too when
the baby is born I I couldn't believe
both my daughters did this you know they
when they're born it's like they can't
even see like they were they were in
they were they were like amphibious when
they're first born it's like this this
thing was living underwater announced
reduction for the first time can't see
doesn't know anything that's going on
and they immediately put the baby on the
mother on the chat on the the chest of
the mother and my both my daughters
instinctively just went down found the
nipple and started knowing that's
exactly where the milk is wow so what
happens is I think what I've noticed
with I believe in like a more like
Oneness and
higher power whatever that is I'm not
saying it's God it's whatever you want
it to be but Ron Hubbard yes L Ron
Hubbard because because I think that you
know this child when I saw like what
nature did instinctively I'm like this
can't have been created in a lab like
I'm not a simulation like I mean or if
it is it's so far Advanced like we never
know anyway no matter what Elon Musk
said I'm like how this is like a
spiritual thing where I'm like how does
this child know how to do everything and
then the body you're like you said the
hair falling out
um um you know the the the different
hormonal imbalances you have like you
have no control of your body right now
it's also really wild like sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt that but
um also your body will tell you what you
need in this crazy way like like you'll
wake up and be like I need to eat 36
strawberries yeah I don't know what
needs I'm making toenails I'm making
eyelashes the next day strawberries
nauseating you need just a giant steak
that's what it is it's so wild when
you're like I'm just a zombie yeah and I
can't even articulate it and I'm like I
don't even know what sense that is right
it's hunger but it's also like yeah it's
so um Advanced right and you did it
right like you you know you had a
successful career you know you didn't
get canceled yet but hopefully that's
happening have I not actually I guess
you have I guess in a way we all have in
some small and some some bigger than
others like the OG way like my sitcom
publicly like everyone was happy yeah
and when I had the show come out people
were so mean to me about it I got like
the old school shit it was not about a
word I said it was about like we don't
we're mad at you yes yeah it was like
yeah
say the n-word you weren't in blackface
like you didn't say anything trans
wasn't even a thing I had an episode
where Natasha legere came on the show
and she played a trans person
yeah they were just like we don't like
that you're successful now you have your
success and now you're kind of going
into this phase of life where like being
a mom or being a parent it's like you're
gonna find that I feel like that your
life before this was amazing and
beautiful but now you have like a true
purpose because everything that you did
now matters so much more I'm not saying
people that don't have kids like they
don't have purpose but I know the ones
of us who do have kids like we for sure
know like my I know what my purpose is
it's like I'm a father first I'm like
it's about my children and then
everything else is secondary and it
takes the sting off the re of our
business with how much regret we go
through and how much failure and
rejection it's like oh it's so it
doesn't any rejection it's like oh I'm
not gonna get that gig where I go to New
York for three months cool I get to
spend more time exactly it's like it
doesn't matter like I'm not competing
with anybody because I'm like I just
care about my children so it's like it
saves you you where I'm like I don't I'm
not looking at what other people are
doing I'm hap I'm only nothing but happy
for that because I'm like I just care
about my kids my kids are happy and
healthy so it's a beautiful thing for
the people who say like you can't I
can't have a kid right now or my career
comes first they're not understanding
that the kid is going to save you I
that's huge like it's interesting I
remember Donald Glover uh you know was
very successful I mean this I'm this was
maybe like five years ago he's super
successful he's on community he's doing
stand-up he's a rapper he's Childish
Gambino and then all of a sudden someone
sends me a video of him on Fallon
singing Redbone shirtless like I thought
it was I thought it was Marvin Gaye I
just heard it and then I was like yeah
it's Donald Glover and I texted him I
was like yo like no offense but like
what happened right and he went I had a
kid yeah there you go like it just you
hit a new gear creatively and you see
the world differently you all of a
sudden aren't and I mean for me I have
to be honest like this was not like I
always wanted to get pregnant at 40. I
was like let me have kids at 40 and 42
let me break all the ancestral Cycles
make sure I've healed all my invisible
wounds my nightmare would be to project
or recreate what was done to me to a
child like I wanna I wanna give my kid a
high chance of being legally retarded so
I'm going to the older I get I wanna I
wanna increase the Down Syndrome odds so
you're like okay
however old sperm is the thing that is
the most linked to autism
my sperm young Boo
this Show's brought to you by buy
optimizers oh hey y'all I don't know if
you've been
um witnessing my under eye bags for the
past 20 years but she's had giant eye
bags under her eyes chronically for the
past 20 years due to insomnia dude I had
insomnia before it was cool okay I had
insomnia before Tick Tock before the
ability to aimlessly scroll for hours I
used to pace around my house toss and
turn in my bed like Juliette Lewis and
that Melissa Etheridge video I was
basically like Brittany Murphy and Girl
Interrupted only I had more chicken
carcasses under my bed I did I used to
sleepwalk that was bad I would wake up
I'd look in the mirror and thought I'd
been murdered but I was really just
covered in barbecue sauce this is all
true okay I'll save that story for my
one woman show the point is nothing is
more important than sleep okay I'm
telling you
and take this from me I know men you
guys listen when the men say it I'm the
one that's actually had insomnia okay
men they sleep like babies okay and the
major game changer for me has been
magnesium ever since I started adding
magnesium breakthrough to my nightly
routine I've been able to quiet my mind
and you guys know how Wild this mind is
I tame it I get the best sleep of my
life I wake up now that I'm taking this
magnesium supplement I wake up in the
same place I fell asleep
what whiskey used to be the only thing
that could do that I literally never
wake up in my car anymore
once I started taking magnesium break
through my sleep completely changed now
I have no problem falling asleep waking
up refreshed and feeling energized
unlike other magnesium supplements that
might be giving you one to two forms of
magnesium magnesium breakthrough
contains all seven forms of magnesium
designed to help calm your mind and help
you fall asleep stay asleep and wake up
refreshed over 75 of the population is
magnesium deficiency yeah
those weirdos with the big oversized
mugs that say like don't talk to me
before I'd have my coffee that's not
normal
that we're doing this okay and when most
people don't even know is that even if
they're taking a magnesium supplement
they're still deficient because they're
not getting all seven forms magnesium
breakthrough is the ultimate way to give
your body all seven forms in One
supplement I don't know why I'm holding
it that way
in addition to experiencing relaxed
sleep magnesium breakthrough also helps
improve digestion this is so true
supports Muscle Recovery and support
healthy bone density most magnesium
supplements are proven to be ineffective
because they only contain one to two
forms of magnesium who has time for that
this has all seven I said it did you
hear it don't miss out on the most
relaxing sleep ever with magnesium
breakthrough for an exclusive offer for
my listeners let's go to
magbreakthrough.com slash Whitney use
promo code Whitney during checkout to
save 10
magbreakthrough.com slash Whitney code
Whitney for ten percent off high
optimizers thank you my under eye bags
are gone look at that
do you see
I mean
I look younger than my baby
I mean they call a female at 35 a
geriatric pregnancy right did you have
to get that amniocentesis thing where
they stick that long ass needle through
and they're gonna have to do that and
test your baby's uh DNA I think um
that's like a like a Brooklyn thing
right they stop doing that out here 25
years ago they don't have someone come
in after fixing the carburetor and jam
the giant fucking steak Knife into their
stomach anymore no they don't do that
anymore we just got a test like a doctor
in Brooklyn right now I was like I got a
test to see if the kids retarded so uh
you want to have it or no it'll take a
car antenna yeah anymore and just stab
your girlfriend that is like that's just
like no can you get it give me an
abortion that's legal please yeah no two
but that was the test to see if a baby
was retired in utero
um but they kind of don't do it they
don't do it anymore yeah I guess because
they would they would that's how crazy
like literally like within the last 15
years they would do that at and then if
your child had some type of disability
they're like do you want to get rid of
this and they're like they didn't have
it and we just gave it one by poking it
in the fucking brain that doesn't have a
skull and this is something by the way
that's kind of funny that moms do um I
mean it's horrifying but uh like I know
some someone that lost one of two twins
that way because it can burst the
amniotic sack sure like it comes with a
lot of risks and when you're pregnant
women will come up to you and tell you
all the horrible ways your child can die
yeah but I I know I'm on Jasmine I'll
tell you too like Jasmine we went
through a lot and you know but but um
like stuff in utero stuff in utero lost
couple of kids yeah like that's it's
just like part of yeah life you know but
yeah it's all it is true like all that
shit just makes you stronger and you
control what you can control you got
good prenatal care you're doing what you
got to do but I gotta say like you know
yes I was waiting and I had frozen eggs
and I always knew I was gonna do it I
think I was always you know I rescue
dogs I was I did always think like oh I
should adopt yeah sure you know like
having your own kids like like buying a
dog from a breeder you know it was like
but also as soon as I lost my mom died
my dad died this kind of biological urge
comes up I killed them
you've done it sooner
um
so that's why you check if your baby's
retarded in the South
um and uh I guess I just like the relief
of the sort of
um extricating from the narcissism of
just yes yourself like it's like I mean
I don't think it's just what we do for a
living but just kidding like
don't you guys get sick of yourselves
like you know I just was like so sick of
myself I just want to love something so
badly and I think I was doing it with
like you know rescuing comics and men
and dogs and horses and you're just like
no that's so obvious the selflessness
that comes with parenting is something
that I think only parents can understand
and I think that you know because it's
it's like one of those things where
they're the only it's the only person in
your life now that you didn't choose
this is chosen for you this soul is
chosen for you so you don't you don't
know why but this this baby is like now
every other person in your life you
chose whether you think it or not you
chose it interesting not this one this
is the only one in the world chosen for
you so it becomes this thing where I'm
like well that must mean something
higher and deeper than I can understand
so this has to be my life now because
this was given to me by the Universe I I
don't I can't explain I can't articulate
it I have is that what Jazzy makes you
call her now well the University
wow yeah I know yeah I know she's um
she's at times like when I like she's
like she's like you're at times she's
like you know like when I try to you
know like focus on the kids and talk
like this she's like you know I'm happy
that you're so into this but like are
you gay
he's like aren't you like just a gay man
because that's okay too I love her she's
like you gave me two children fag yeah
yeah I know it was funny when she when
you texted me about your baby shower you
were like hey hey Jazz um you know like
you were to texting me and you were like
jazz don't worry like this is Whitney
I'm like a few months pregnant and I
told that to Jazz and Jazz like like
that would stop you you know that you
would still go after a pregnant bitch
you nasty that's even better because
yeah you know she can't get pregnant
yeah and then she liked it yeah I didn't
even say that like she said that and
then she like yelled at me and like
wouldn't talk to me for an hour and then
came back and she's like baby you want
eggs what do you want what okay so
really quick we joke but is I like
asking men about the vagina thing
instead of because usually when I ask
guys they're like it's the same she
thinks it's super different but like
yeah you know it is it is the same it
goes back it goes back it totally went
back I mean because literally I mean she
you know she has three kids and I mean
she does the key goal I bet she knows
all the stuff to do because she's
exercising exercise I mean my kids have
huge heads I'm telling you they ripped
through that thing and it was um all
back you know were you in the room oh
yeah yeah in the room what's the number
one thing that
you wish someone had told you
um okay the one thing that I think what
I they didn't they did tell me but I
forgot is do not look down as the man
this is just from the man's point do not
look down as the baby as the baby's
coming out because it's one of those
things where you have to understand
you're pushing so it's like everything
is there blood fluid so do not look down
because it's not even like oh then she's
gonna be unattractive to you for me that
didn't happen it's like you get more
it's the mother of my child so it's like
a deeper connection where it's like the
most attractive she could be it for me
is like right she almost died for you
but it's like for me it's like I I look
at that stuff and I'm like I what you're
shit and piss all over my baby's head
you know and I'm like what what's their
niece yeah well no I guess it yeah I
guess well like no it's just as it's
coming out it's just it's just a
fountain of fluid and and and and and
and it was all over my shoes
yeah don't wear your new shit don't wear
your nude
but I think I think it's all over the
floor
um yes what one so it's it's interesting
because you know listen the thing is too
anything like you you're you're
everything's gonna be fine but there's a
lot of I wouldn't have a lot of people
I'm not I'm no good don't worry because
some people yeah we I don't have any
friends we know this I know you have no
family no friends Tim Dylan's going to
be in the corner I think my agent might
be coming Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Tim
will be live streaming from patreon yeah
yeah so not good
and so so
um um so I think because you know like
with my the youngest one Violet
everything you know it was like my
second baby that it was all fun before
the the the OBGYN great ladies like you
know Chris you'll cut the cord it it'll
be amazing and we're put Jazz got an
epidural for that one so she's actually
like it was an easier yeah she's
chilling everything's good and then the
baby and then she's like you know uh uh
you could see like the doctor's face
start to change a little bit when
they're going through it and then she
said to she said Jazz honey you need to
push right now you have to give it all
you got because she's like she was just
honest she was like so concerned she's
like that the cord is wrapped around the
baby's neck so you have to push and then
it became like so tense where Jazz had
to like go in like your baby realized
Chris is its dad and it's hanging itself
exactly exactly when my first kid came
out Delilah just came out she's like oh
look I got a white daddy it was like a
lottery
yay
where Violet didn't know because you
know I had a mask on it was the pandemic
she's like is that motherfucker white oh
no
I can't tell based on his hair he's
Persian yes yeah he looks like a big
lesbian I know do you think that had
something to do with the no epidural and
epidural because she thinks she couldn't
feel it I don't think I think that it's
just fate it's just like nature and then
you know the babe it turned into it's
going to be this happy moment cut the
cord or whatever to like get that baby
out wasn't you know it was like purple
violet was like purple that's why we
named her violet
yeah hey honey where are my name come
from you were asphyxiated as a baby so
we just thought it makes sense but just
immediately grabbed her the nurse
grabbed the baby by grabbed my daughter
by the foot and like rushed her over to
a thing and like then we heard cries and
everything was fine and she had like a
big bruise on her face for a while and
I've seen okay it was like still to I
just you know this happened two and a
half years ago my daughter's fine but
like jazz is so protective of the little
one because of that Moment Like This
maternal Instinct that she's told me
she's like I'm never gonna be able to
let that go from her like I locked her
trauma like birth trauma she had it with
her she was like birth trauma in her
life I cannot like she's much more kind
of lacks with the other ones like you
know attentive to them but like not on
top of every move where this one she's
like oh my God oh my God so you know I
think like advice is like just have it
be you and you're a partner like it's
like your moment like my first baby I
didn't realize that and like I you know
I we have Jasmine like spread eagle like
you know my mom was there so it's
obviously making her a little bit
uncomfortable not even her own mom was
there my mom was there and then my dad
my fucking dad literally the baby is
like crowning my dad I swear to Christ
my dad Tampa Tony walks in just through
the door he goes we having a baby is it
a boy or a girl and I was like we had a
gender reveal you know it's a girl he
goes I don't know if things could change
and then
and then Jasmine goes Jasmine goes she
goes she goes because she was just like
in the she was like Tony please like you
have to get out please I'm like
screaming back he goes oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry he goes Chris he goes let me know
when the baby's born he goes by the way
Yankees got fucking rocks
he goes Samantha gave up two homies why
don't we give this guy all right
and I was like what the fuck
why do I feel like he was punching a
vending machine trying to get out of
butterfinger and then I go in I go out
there you know whatever 20 minutes later
he's like what how do we do I'm like you
know it's a baby girl she got rocks
right I know he got he goes so it's
ain't a boy huh I was like how many
times do we have to tell you it's a girl
and he goes that's all right she could
still play sports I was like yeah well
isn't there I maybe I'm generalizing too
much I feel like all my most masculine
guy friends have daughters is there
something even even more than that I
feel like I was shocked when you told me
that you were having a boy because I was
like everybody I know is having girls
and everybody I've known for the past
few years I'm like everybody's having
girls like really girls so many girls
but I think bro like like Rogan Jocko
willick like the big like I feel like
Pat like I feel like man man man girls
is there something primordial about like
oh you're the you can protect her I
think well the three guys you just met
we're all firmly in the closet so I
think all the pushing down of our
homosexuality which is Raging that it
just turned our sperms I just want so
badly to shop in that Target yeah two
two sections yeah it's why it's like
it's I just always wonder if there's
some connection between a lot of
testosterone listen I think it could be
I'm sure like Cutting Edge science can
tell you like this type of guy because
obviously we know now you know that we
just the male just determines the sex
I'm sure that there is something but I I
all I know is like yeah every time Jazz
got pregnant I was like I know that
that's a girl I know that it's so weird
and then when I it's so interesting that
you were because every time uh someone I
told someone I had a boy they were like
I knew it you're such a girl a boy mom
boy mom yeah yeah see the thing you know
I have two daughters but they're still
circumcised I circumcised the boss of
them just because my father really
wanted a boy
yo dude busy fall season already in
swing are you looking for wholesome
convenient meals for your jam-packed
days I am factor is America's number one
ready to eat meal kit it can help you
fuel up with fast and delicious Chef
prepared dietitian approved ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
you'll save time you'll eat well you'll
stay on track with your healthy
lifestyle too busy this fall to cook or
flat out don't want to because you're
you know it's too tempting to put your
head in the oven when you do
but also want to make sure you're eating
well with Factor skip the extra trip to
the grocery store skip the chopping and
the prepping and the cleaning and the
while still getting delicious flavor and
nutritional quality that you need
factors fresh never frozen meals are
ready in just two minutes so you have
all you have to do is eat and enjoy then
get back to crushing them goals suggest
your stride this Autumn without missing
a step choose from 34 plus weekly flavor
packed fresh never frozen meals ready to
eat in two minutes level up with Gourmet
plus options prepare to Perfection by
chefs and ready to eat in record time
treat yourself to upscale meals with
premium ingredients like broccolini
leeks truffle butter and asparagus
looking for calorie conscious options
during the busy season try delicious
dietitian approved calorie smart meals
with around or less than 550 calories
per serving I'm obsessed with Factor
when I tell you I eat one of these a day
I'm not exaggerating in some capacity
their breakfast is my new obsession okay
it's being pregnant I wake up starving
to death because this tiny little
vampire is eating my bone marrow from
the inside
I love that there's they have apple
cinnamon pancakes that are Bonkers bacon
and cheddar those little egg bites
delicious then
um potato bacon egg breakfast it's like
a skillet thing put some hot sauce on
there you're ready to go they also do
smoothies cold pressed juices shakes you
name it the factor you can rest assured
you're making sorry about my burping I'm
burping up a factor smoothie frankly
you're making a sustainable choice they
offset 100 of their delivery emissions
Source 100 renewable electricity for all
our production sites and office there I
just said hour because now I've decided
I
the company and I work together they
have not invited me to work with them so
I'm going to say their production sites
and offices they feature sustainably
sourced Seafood in their meals no Angry
orcas not on factors watch
head to factormeals.com Whitney 55-0 and
use code whitney50 to get 50
50 off that's crazy code whitney50 at
factormeals.com whitney50 to get 50 off
how soon can you have sex after we
Jasmine and I had sex I want to say
six weeks okay because you know stitches
and all that you know you just can't I
want to say it was roughly about roughly
about six I mean blow jobs go lower but
you know
no I would say six weeks I think the
doctors tell you six weeks you know
what's crazy my first daughter this is I
love that like if she hears this like
you know 15 years ago think about that
do you think about that stuff I do but
I'll take it all down I don't I own
YouTube will be gone it truly it will be
like a library like this will be like a
like an Encyclopedia Britannica what am
I what do me and my kids can hear this
in the Chinese prison camp it's like no
and and so and so so I I do sometimes
I'm like you know talk but I we're open
with our kids about like especially like
what I do like the older ones like where
like I talk about you guys for a living
protect the innocent I'm not gonna ever
talk about like intricate moments in
their life but like things with jazz and
I will talk about like being a parent so
when she was pregnant
my older one she was like four days late
right and the the Doula we had a doula
for for that one you know like Jewish
fucking Midwife like extraordinaire like
this lady just like cultivates I can
just get the babies out she was like one
trick is and this has been around for
centuries she goes if you want to get
your if you want to have this baby she
goes what you're gonna have to do she
said to Jack she goes you're gonna have
to swallow semen when you swallow semen
how much did you pay the Doula to that's
what I said I was like I was like yo I
was like Sarah my girl and you know blow
jobs prevent birth defects yes yeah yeah
and so and so she was like I can't
believe that like no way I'm not doing
it like I'm sick to my you know like I'm
feel nauseous all the time and whatever
and then she's like walking around
pacing and I'm just sitting there and
then I I'm just sitting there on the
couch you know and she's just like
pacing like doing breathing
slowly
and then you just come in her face
and then finally she was like she was
like give it to me
and then she just did it and it was
fucking quick and it and I swear to God
it happened I I she will admit to this
she would unfortunately she would admit
about an hour accidentally fucking water
burst we my daughter was born like
within three hours born just a full load
just swallowed it and then bang so if
you're finding yourself in that position
you know we're available
[Laughter]
I'll just hold up like a picture of his
podcast
so yeah that's interesting because that
must be the body's way of going like
we're ready for another one something in
the properties yeah and it's like it's
crazy how like you know uh like you'll
when and when the baby comes like I
can't explain it like you're gonna
obviously have like even if you have a
nanny and all that and and and you know
you'll have like these sleepless nights
at times but then yes the next morning
you're tired and exhausted but like if I
told you if you told me Hey your baby's
not gonna sleep or they're gonna sleep
you know they're gonna wake up every two
hours there's no way you'll be able to
function the next day and like somehow
you're able to function like somehow
nature gives you like these surges of
energy to be like yeah like even even
all the hormones in your body once you
after you give birth you have like
diuretics in your body like natural fat
burning chemicals in your body because
your body is like let's get let's let
this this is the only the only you're
having been having periods every month
for your whole life since you were seven
I don't know you know knowing it
I don't even know
give it you know I don't I feel like you
hit puberty early you were like six
eight you know like just walking around
third grade
I apological schlatters in my knees yeah
so so like your body every month has
been like preparing for it and it's not
happening not happening and now it
happens so it's like your body's like oh
shit this is what we do we're designed
to do so it wants it again that whole
like sleeping eight hours thing or like
that's when I had nothing to live for
right you know what I mean it's like the
idea of like getting up like I'm already
sleeping in these like intermittent like
your body already starts preparing it
looks good to get up and pee so much
you're like getting up every three hours
and I'm not like oh and I'm like okay
this is good this is like I'm learning
to sleep in three hour increments right
you'll also notice too like at least
something with me like I really I only
have a finite amount of energy yeah each
day so I'm not I'm not gonna spend it on
like like my boys group chat will be
like you know my boys who don't have
kids like they'll be talking about like
did you see what this guy did or that
and it's like I don't look at any of
that shit I'm like I I'll comment on
stuff here and there but it's like I
gotta spend and it's all like stuff like
right now my kids are on the other side
of the country but I'm still like I'm
gonna I gotta keep energy and keep it up
because like when we need to FaceTime
later on they need to ask me anything
it's like it's all subconscious I'm like
my Energy's for them like my whole
purpose is for them so it's like you
start to really say no to a lot of
things yeah already already time becomes
more valuable than money but interesting
because it also thinks I'm so grateful
for the clarity that has come like I
used to have such bad decision fatigue
right people like oh do you want to do
you know I don't know Family Feud for
this charity fake charity and with this
and you're just like I guess I should do
that because what if the and then all
the shit the machinations of like I
might get a tick tock clip out of it and
it's not a lot and I'll and I'll move
and then you're like no no it feels so
good yeah now I'm just like okay like
you want me to go away for x amount of
time and and I'm like the opportunity
the cost of that to me me is too much if
it's like more than like a month away
and like you want me to go it's like all
I'm gonna do is Miss time with my kids
it's not there's no money that's worth
it so I'd rather make less money and
have more time with them like money is
not a distinguishing Factor yeah he's
like um yeah
this is why she thinks you're gay I know
she's like what the fuck yeah well no I
had to just pay like you know a good
amount of money for it to get her tits
out she wanted her implants removed I
was like I'm not paying for that was she
did she
bitch
yeah yeah yeah yeah
no she was saying because she was saying
like you know having daughter she wanted
to get them removed because she was like
you know I feel like I literally have a
foreign object in my body which I do it
makes me crazy she she was saying it
makes me feel unsettled she was like and
I don't want our daughter she was like
no disrespect to any woman who wants to
get plastic surgery she said but me
being a role model I don't want them to
think they have to alter their bodies
exactly I got Christmas stuff and she
was like yeah I got the guy from
[Laughter]
yeah but wait so was she able to
breastfeed with implants so that's that
was a big thing for her because she got
implants they didn't you know whatever
do it properly whatever and sometimes
they'll cut through exactly she couldn't
hey just assume when you get breast
implants you're like you should never be
a mother yeah
fuck this yeah so they so she couldn't
and that was a big like it upset her
even though obvious course our babies
were fed formula with all that because
she couldn't do it yeah it destroyed her
for so she was like I'm I I'm not I'm
getting these out and I'm and I'm moving
on and I was like all right well like
let's keep him in a freezer or something
you want to get him all the way at least
let's just take one out see how you feel
it's just a lot of hormones happening
Yeah
well yeah because I have but we'll see I
mean we'll see yeah the formula yeah the
formula's so good now yeah it's good now
and I think that not everybody there's
there's women you know who she knew who
got implants who there was no problem
interesting so it's just but I think
like again being a mom like you just
start to like reevaluate you know yeah
every priorities I mean your priorities
and you're like you know what can I
control what can I control like yes
we're all connected and I want the world
to be a better place and and all that
but I have my job is is these kids and
my my immediate family so I can't let
something that's like really I can't
change at all like sometimes I feel like
people that are like getting involved in
every cause it is a bit of narcissism
where it's like you just don't have a
purpose like you I I still get we still
get involved because I think something
happening on the other side of the world
can affect me and my family because
we're all one but it's like sometimes
when I see people going crazy I'm like
you think you're like being selfless but
it's actually selfish this is all about
you yeah you have to find some reason to
exist for some reason you have no
purpose yeah and it's tricky because
there are those people who are like
having kids is irresponsible right now
there's gonna be no water and you're
like well good and I can't drama yeah
you know what look at my yeah my tits
will make the water yeah but it's also
like yeah I I I see you and look if kids
aren't for you that's totally fine I was
that person I think if you don't think
you want them please don't have them I
agree but you just don't be so arrogant
that you don't think your mind is going
to change as you get older and you lose
family members and you start being less
high on your supply of whatever success
bullshit
oh gosh you guys I want to talk to you
about Shopify a little while ago I had
this idea that I wanted to sell t-shirts
and sweatshirts with horses on them
because I'm an American hero and that's
what people like me do because I have
dreams and my dreams are for you all to
look like you only shop at fancy gas
stations
but I had no idea where to get started I
don't know how to start a business I
know how to sell stuff that's why I'm so
glad I found Shopify and by finding I
mean everyone told me you should use
Shopify okay so it's like look if you
wait too long on a punch line you're
gonna kill the joke you make your
customer wait too long for checkout and
you're gonna lose the sale
okay Power your business with the
internet's best converting checkout
experience get Shopify Shopify is so
easy to use I'm I'm inspired to start
even more businesses it's so easy I'm
gonna finally get my bumper sticker
Venture off the ground and I may even
start selling my hot takes for five
bucks a piece Shopify is the Commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide whether you're a
garage entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify
is the only tool you need to start run
and grow your business without the
struggle Shopify puts you in control of
every sales channel so whether you're
selling satin sheets from shopify's in
person POS system or offering organic
olive oil on shopify's all-in-one
e-commerce platform you're covered and
once you've reached your audience
Shopify has the internet's best
converting checkout to help you turn
them from browsers to buyers Shopify
Powers 10 of all e-commerce in the
United States and Shopify is truly a
global Force powering all birds rothies
and Brook Lennon and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across over
170 countries plus shopify's
award-winning help is there to support
your successes every step of the way
this is possibility powered by Shopify
sign up for one dollar per month trial
period at shopify.com Whitney all
lowercase go to shopify.com Whitney to
take your business to the next level
today shopify.com Whitney
kitchen
server team boy and girl
so I have a 13 year old stepson and then
I have my my two daughters I I mean the
big difference is you know I mean the
big difference is obviously you know I
don't love my stepson
um
that's what makes them hard
if you had a boy would you circumcise uh
yeah I believe I would yeah yeah
actually yeah my stepson wasn't
circumcised and I went ahead and gone
yeah insult his father no no I do love
my stepson my stepson it's great to have
boy because what I see like how what a
protector he is like especially my
little one like he's a protected like
natural protection him and my
eight-year-old argue locks a little
closer in age but I know he protects her
too but I think that it is true like the
the and I don't know what it is but like
my stepson is so close with his mom like
Jasmine like boy like your mommy's
little boy kind of thing like it's so
close and I'm so close with my daughters
and she is too but it's like but her and
the daughters are also gonna have like
I'm so glad I had a boy first because I
I don't think I'd be able to take the
first of all the girls clothes kind of
stresses me out right it's just like I
saw my girlfriend has is having a girl
and the registry just look like JonBenet
Ramsey's evidence list
like like mini skirts and tutus and
little girl cow girl boots and shit like
I just I was like I definitely wanted a
boy first just to not project my shit
onto them right but there is girls no
girls games no game you know you have to
manipulate you have to cajole you have
to see we can get away with it always
already like I have no I mean already
Jasmine will tell me how much my
daughters manipulate me already and
she's like and you don't understand at
all she's like you're such an idiot like
how you don't understand that they're
constantly manipulating you constantly
manipulating you like my daughter like a
couple of months ago she wanted to she
must have asked Jazz to like go on the
iPad I said no I I didn't know I was
downstairs and then she comes down you
know doesn't even have the iPad she
doesn't even have the iPad at all it's
like in another room and she just comes
and she sits on my lap like what she
does she just sits on my lap and she's
like laying on my chest and she hears
like my heart beating she's like oh wow
daddy she's like your heart's beating so
fast I'm like and I'm like oh I'm like
well you know because I love you so much
every time you know I'm I get happy
she's like you make me so happy Daddy
and I'm like I'm like oh you do too and
then I was like you you know you changed
my whole life and she's like I love you
she's like you really are like the best
dad you know what I'd love to do Google
you yeah I know I want to see more
photos yeah and then she goes and she
was like and she was like
you know like you're like strong and
everything and I was like oh thanks and
she and then she says to me and then she
says to me and then it was like a it was
like a Mr Mac she was like she's like
you want to go outside she's like let's
go outside and like play in the
playground she was like and I was like
love it like off the device let's play
in the playground and then we're like
playing on the playground for like 15
minutes like loving it having great time
and then I said to her she I said to her
I was like you know what babe because it
started to like drizzle a little bit I
was like we go inside and I was like I
was she was like what do you want to do
now and I was like I was like you want
to like watch something she's like I
don't know she's like why don't you
watch she was like we already played or
whatever she's like why don't you watch
like a show and I'll watch what I want
to watch on the iPad I was like great we
had some outside time whatever and then
next thing you know she's on the iPad
and Jasmine comes down you know a few
minutes later she's like why is Delilah
on the iPad I was like well we played
outside and you know I'm watching my own
thing and she was like I just told her
she can't go on the iPad you know an
hour ago and now she she's on the iPad
and then I was explaining it to Jazz
what happened she was like but she said
I was strong exactly she was like she
came downstairs you have to understand
Chris she came downstairs with the full
intent of said I'm going to manipulate
this dumb motherfucker I'm gonna rope
him in with bullshit after bullshit and
then I'm gonna get that iPad and then I
was like Wow and it's true where my
stepson doesn't do that at all my
stepson coming to go I watch the iPad
mom said no
and then on the back wallet mom said no
then I can't override these fucking
family sucks
so so I think there is you know what's
another wild fact about girls when my
daughter was both my daughters when they
were in utero like when they were I
think it's like eight weeks when they
were like eight weeks in gestation in
Jasmine's belly they already had all the
eggs that they were having for their
entire life so it's like nature is just
like right away is like give him the
seats that's why I'm kind of like like
when babies have girl babies have baby
dolls Falls I'm always like uh why are
we training them to do this okay that I
will say though that's I think that's me
projecting right well they love it well
yeah they because that's the thing is
like I never really told and jazzed we
never were like putting dolls in their
faces they grab it they like that they
already do yeah they like the dolls and
and my stepson likes trucks like he just
I think it's how I think it's just sort
of awkward how innate that is right how
within them it is well I also live on
Staten Island so like it's a different
place like like homework my like my
daughter's Homer goes to a Catholic
school they came home with like a
coloring sheet like this is you know a
year ago this is in the middle of like
everything they come home she comes home
with a coloring sheet all girl school
and it was uh uh um what men do and what
women do and the women the woman that my
last four specials yes exactly and the
women and the women the woman you have
to do this coloring activity the woman
was in the kitchen putting muffins in an
oven and the man and Had A Hammer with
the nail against the wall yeah
I was like wow what a fucking what a
world we like you know they kind of are
like one like men are horrible at making
muffins yes we are I'm good at eating
them let's not protect you know I I
don't know I think I don't know that's
like it's all gotten so extreme like why
can't a woman make a fucking muffin yeah
well I am going to be very nice if a guy
would just hang a fucking thing yeah
yeah I might not that I can't I'm just
you live in a role reversal relationship
like I don't know how to fix or do
anything I know to do nothing that a man
knows how to do the other day Jasmine
was putting up sheetrock like just
putting up sheetrock in um the the guest
room just putting it up and I walked in
saw that I could do nothing and assist
with nothing so I went in and I made
fresh lemonade and I brought in lemonade
like a 50s housewife and my girls know
like they're like if anything needs to
be fixed or like when deliveries come
like when God they get the mom like the
delivery guys be like where's your
father and she'll be like it'll be like
uh I don't know what my father's fucking
doing a podcast
well you need you need my mom she's the
one that assembles all this stuff so we
live in and but my point is even with
that even with role reversal my
daughters are seeing especially my Earl
they're seeing a woman who is kind of
like in the you know traditional male
role my daughter still gravitates
towards dolls gravitates towards being
girly is boy crazy so some of this stuff
I think is like hardwired you get like
in a society now like we get we want to
change all these things it's like we're
not the human something Society projects
I agree but some things is nature it's
like nature the fact that a woman is
like the one giving birth to the baby
and making the baby and then the baby
gravity because you came out of the
woman's body it's like that's not a
patriarchal thing I didn't choose that
the Universe chose that I so it's like
it's not
a man's fault if like the woman is the
one that the baby's crying out for and
the woman's is like unfortunately the
where the career has to stop a little
bit it's like Nature's decide I didn't
decide that nature decided that so it's
like what what the fuck do you want me
to do it's also tricky because like I
see so many of my friends that don't
want to just surrender to being like
moms like they still want to like be the
CEO and they still want to run all this
and I'm just like I'm just glad that I'm
doing it late at a time where I'm like
I'm gonna take a year off yeah and I'm
just gonna like be a ma I don't want to
look back if the kids fucked I want to
know it was my fault at least you know
what I mean it like right I want at
least I like doing things really well
and I'm like I just want to do this well
like yeah old-fashioned way I was
talking to a guy who's having his first
kid and he's like I'm terrified and I'm
like there's nothing what it's this this
is freeing you like this is you're
actually there's nothing to be because
now you you know exactly what you have
to do on this Earth it's like your main
your only job now is to make sure this
kid has a good easy life yes I need to
be happy so that gets transferred onto
my children so I have to still do what I
want to do and go to work of course but
it's like this idea of like that as long
as my children's basic needs are met
because it doesn't take a lot to have a
happy life people think you need this
and that no like you can have and you
can have a very very happy life I think
people stop wanting a happy life people
now want a life other people are jealous
of sure yeah I feel like people stop
wanting to be happy right and they
started wanting other people to Envy
them or something I'm like what are you
going for right and a lot of times you
know you'll get things you know for for
people you don't know to impress people
you'll never meet and it's like
comparison is the thief of Joy I don't
getting off social media was the most
radical thing I could have done whoa so
someone posts your stuff for you I don't
have any access to it anymore and that
was all by Design because I was like how
much time am I spending here scrolling
doing this when it's like those are all
moments I could spend with the children
or compare it comparing even sometimes I
would even compare me to me I would look
at me from six months oh I like that guy
better but it's like that guy had a
perfectly crafted photo that was like
the ninth pick that I chose to post and
you your brain makes you forget that
yeah and then you just start to in the
present start to get like oh I I don't
like who I am right now when it's like I
don't do that at all anymore I don't
know what I look like eight months ago I
have no idea when was there like a rock
bottom for this or like a moment you
were like I'm done I'm done yeah I was
like I I Jasmine told me yeah yeah yeah
exactly yeah you're awesome yeah um I I
was like uh you know um last year on my
birthday I was like
you just turned 38 I felt like it was
one of those years where I was like
every year on my birthday I'd be like
I'm gonna be 40 pounds lighter I'm gonna
I'm gonna get myself back in shape I'm
gonna do any every birthday I was like
I'm not every birthday I was like I I I
hated myself on my birthday and then I
was like last year I was like you know
what I'm gonna fucking do I I kind of
like it just was like I was like I'm
gonna start fasting I'm gonna start
intermittent fasting and I was like I I
I eat like I can't be the guy that's
like I'm keto I only eat salads it would
never work for me so I'm like if I can
just change my eating window this will
change my life and I got I download this
app called the zero fasting app I saw
Elon Muska tweeted about it my God and
so I saw he had tweeted about it and I
looked into it and I said just try this
try this for three months but I said and
then I I wasn't thinking about getting
off social media yet all I was thinking
about was only eat in an eight-hour
window only eat fast for 16 hours and
eat an eight that's all I was doing and
then I would do that every day keep
doing it Jasmine was like you know very
supportive of me she was like if it was
a minute after my if I was a minute
outside My fasting window she would take
the food away in the beginning she was
like if we're gonna do this you got to
do this and be strict and so
I you know at that point it was like
unbalanced because I was like I just
need to get this habit down and then
without me even really having a
wholehearted thought about it I was like
you know what makes keeps me sick too
mentally social media I was like start
fasting with social media and I said to
this my friend I was like can you run
this I'll pay you to run it and he was
like sure and took it out took it away
from me and then because what would
always happen like clockwork because I
would always get to a certain point you
know get to a certain level of health
and exercise you know in the past and
then I would go be subconsciously
scrolling on social media and see
someone who's jacked ripped or start to
compare myself to them and be like I've
been working so hard and I don't even
have a tenth of what they have and then
it's not like it's a it's not like it's
a decision oh uh give me a cheeseburger
it's all subconscious and it slowly then
starts to become what's the point why
amazing why bother so and then that
hasn't happened to me now because there
is no comparison I'm just like like you
think you're the most in-shaped person
oh yeah oh yeah I think I'm yeah I'm
like
that because and and or even like with
our careers like I would go do a show in
a city and you know be happy that I sold
out or whatever and then I used and then
but like you know with the algorithms
they would show you like some of one of
our other peers is going to be there
next week and they have three shows sold
out so immediately my sellout would feel
insignificant to me where now it doesn't
because now I'm like now my whole
mindset has changed where it's like
money and ticket sales and all that it's
just one aspect so I'm sure you can't
even celebrate your wins because you're
gonna have find someone that's winning
harder and I realize now it's like
everybody is better or worse like we're
all there's so many moving variables and
someone's looking at you going ah he
sold out yeah and I came you know what I
mean
also right but we're not thinking that
doesn't matter so that's why now I just
absolutely I control what I can control
what I can control is exercising eating
in My fasting window you know you know
you still do that I still do that yeah
that's how I live you know getting my
writing I control my output Not My
outcome I would which was reversed I
used to always be about like if the
outcome wasn't what I wanted to be it
was a failure where now I don't care
about the outcome what am I controlling
what is my output it's all about my
output not about my outcome it's like I
can post something you know a funny clip
from this episode or funny stand-up bit
that I believe is funny and if it
wouldn't get the views or the comments
I'd be like oh it's a failure no I don't
care now I'm like I thought it was funny
so I'm putting it out right and then if
the ticket sales come they come if they
don't know and I think I'm kind of also
at a place where I'm like I'm down to
attract the fans that I'd want to hang
out with yes also do you know I don't
want to trick anybody no you know what I
mean if this didn't hit for everybody
that's totally cool but the people it
did hit with yeah they're gonna come to
shows right and they're my people
exactly and it's not like um but I think
that's what having kids is about too
where it's like that kind of got me into
that mindset where
okay so and so might have more ticket
sales than you or make more money than
you but it's like but they're not a
father or even if they are a father
they're not a father to your kids or
like maybe they are in balance in this
part of their life as I'm in balance in
that part of my life so I real like
LeBron James is a billionaire and a
better basketball player than us but we
may be better at something yeah and he
is it's like you just I feel like
sometimes us as human beings I don't
know why our minds do this but like we
will take one aspect of a person's
existence and make it so big and then
make that person a God and recognize it
against ourselves yeah and say that this
person is fundamentally categorically
better than me in every way and it's
like that's not true there's a homeless
person on the street right now that's
better than you at something but also it
even gets harder when you're like okay I
sell that two shows they sold out three
shows and they're not as funny as me
yeah that also gets tougher you know but
even that even that's all like with our
career specifically it's like it's all
subjective right it's all ego it's like
the fans who you know we may not think
somebody is funny and they're selling
out all the it's like but but their tell
their fans don't it's like I don't like
where my brain goes to have to justify
it so that I don't have to deal with oh
I guess they're winning harder and then
you have to go well and I'm like oh I
just had to do something judgy and gross
and that's and that's the thing I think
with with me with with parenting and
what you'll find is like okay you want
to go trade places with you know X this
comic this actor this athlete well then
that what that will include then is
giving up your children giving up your
way of life because if you want to trade
plays for them you got to go all in it's
not possible but if you wanted to it's
so I think about that it's like there's
we're all like we all have different
things that are good or better or worse
that you know in our lives and I don't
kind of I don't compare I don't compare
at all anymore but even if I was it
would be it wouldn't be like an over
overall thing all-encompassing thing
because I'm like I'm happy with what my
life is and what my children and my you
know my family have and we're happy
doing it my way so it's like I don't
want what anybody else has because if I
I think somebody else had then it would
change the Dynamics of my family and I
don't want that I'm happy with my
existence a couple years ago Brad became
like everyone's enemy all of a sudden
but I just I won't give it up I can't I
shant and I was I wasn't I wasn't I
won't and I shant have it red is
actually my whole life
I can't think of anything more important
to me than Brad now that I think about
it but everyone's telling me it's bad
for me it has too many carbs sugar no
until now enter hero bread herobrad is a
bread that has high fiber low carbs and
zero you heard me zero sugar total Game
Changer because being pregnant all I
want is bread let's be honest I do I did
a hero last night I did the hero
tortilla with some cream cheese in it oh
my God rolled it up cream cheese hero
roll oh God I do a hero bread avocado
toast every morning
and I must say though the tortillas
though dude cook up some steak some sour
cream some salsa little steak bits roll
it up put the bread in the pan for a
minute so it's extra yum yum in my tum
tum I just inhale that oh no guilt
hangover no emotional aftermath no sugar
crash no migraine no waiting in a swamp
of Shame for no reason and normal bread
fills you up so fast that's the other
thing so you can't even finish what you
made hero bread you can just eat and eat
and eat until all your problems
voila disappear hero makes sliced breads
buns and tortillas that are available on
hero.com and Amazon if you are one of
them keto people you will especially
love herobrad because it's super low
carb no sugar it's a miracle I tell you
be the hero of your own movie
and try herobrad get hero dot Co and use
discount code Whitney for 10 off right
now herobrad is offering my listeners 10
off their first order just go to hero.co
and use my code Whitney to save on hero
bread today that's hero dot Co save 10
do it I'd rather be like I have what we
have we have what we have like leave me
and my little family alone where we
don't have that you want to be like it's
all about me yeah pay attention on me
and that's that's always bad like you
always see that crash in Burn where now
kind of like there's these mechanisms
like naturally with my family where it's
like I don't wanna I don't want it to be
all about me I I don't want to be
anybody's Bulls I don't want to be a
Target I want to have the life that I
have and make it easy and kind of even
like with adding shows like I I could
add shows because I'm like you know what
I love being on stage but it's like I
wanna I wanna come out do my shows give
it that audience a hundred percent and
then go have like a nice dinner with the
guys who I work with within like be
present with them like get time back
like yes I'm sacrificing money not
adding a show but I'm getting time back
which is more important and then I'll be
more present and have more energy for my
children when I get home to them so I
think about things where in our business
because it's entertainment I get it you
know our agents and managers always need
like money money money and I get it
they're not bad people but you're also
going to be a better performer a better
podcaster a better everything else if
you have a well-rounded Balanced Life
yeah because it's like I mean it took me
a long time to realize when I was doing
like you know 80 shows a year or
whatever and like working myself and I
was like writing and I would just sit
down and be like what is what do people
what are people's lives like I didn't
know in order for art to imitate life
you have to have a life sure I couldn't
write jokes about going to a baby shower
I couldn't write jokes about like you
know hanging out with friends and
something I just did it because all I
did was work and now you'll connect to
and like you know so many of the people
are going to be coming to your shows
it's like just being a mom talking about
that stuff it's like it's it's a whole
new Lane there's it's like you know like
when you you know writers would like
take a drug Ayahuasca or something like
that like this whole new Lane in their
brain that's what happens with parenting
yeah yeah this whole new life exists
like there's my life like you know first
of all like being able to you know the
one shock it the the hard thing about
parenting as beautiful as it is to be
selfless and just have that natural it's
very difficult like I like the kids were
with my Mom this past weekend for the
first time in like three years and Jazz
and I were able to wake up on a Saturday
morning and just do exactly what we
wanted to do and and and it was weird
like you almost feel like selfish for it
and we were like thinking about the kids
but we were like wow this is what like
our friends who don't have children like
they have so much energy they have so
much they're not I I find that the
people that don't they're not taking it
advantage of it right they're like on
they're waking up and scrolling and
hurting themselves with social media and
they're like just complaining right and
you guys aren't even enjoying this time
right anyway right because I kind of
wasn't because like what I'll say it
what I'll do is like you know and and
Jazz and I have spoken about this where
it's like it's almost like not that I'm
I'm not impressed because it's like
people who you know who don't have
children do amazing things but it's
almost like if you have kids and are
like crushing it like that impresses me
more because I know how exhausting yeah
I know that when you I know that when
the person that doesn't have kids is at
100 by you know 10 o'clock in the
morning firing all cylinders you're
already at like 20 because you have
gotten your energy taken by the kids
immediately you know you have to get
shit done because you got to get out of
there by five I'm here now in L.A and I
was in San Diego like four days ago so I
flew to San Diego did a show for the for
the U.S Navy and then flew back to New
York and you know he doesn't have kids
he's like why won't you just stay in a
stay in Southern California I'm like
because I have to fly home for my kids
you fucking idiot sorry it's Dan Dan
Levy's birth control FaceTiming me
should have thought of that six months
[Applause]
what's up bro we're podcasting
happy b day oh thank you is today your
birthday yeah oh shit I didn't realize
I'm just sitting here talking about
myself happy birthday Whitney I'm so
sorry happy birthday I love you can I
Facetime you back we're talking about
parenting okay bring me up
I love you love you I just get facetimed
by babies now see kids love me I'm so
I'm so I didn't know it was your
birthday oh God I'm so sorry here you
want to go into labor early
that would be the best gift frankly and
now here's a little insight into one of
my therapy sessions with a better help
counselor hey Sue Jo M.A is a licensed
marriage and family therapist with
clinical focus and interest in Asian
American mental Wellness anxiety and
stress management relationship and
family Dynamics and Trauma relief Jesu
is the current head of clinical
operations at betterhelp the world's
largest online therapy service where she
empowers other therapists and being
successful at bringing their skills
online Jesu Joe's input is General
psychological information based on
research and clinical experience it's
intended to be General and informational
in nature it does not represent or
indicate an established clinical or
professional relationship with those
inquiring for guidance also just because
you might have heard something on the
show that sounds similar to what you're
experiencing beware self-diagnosis
diagnosis is not required to find relief
and you'll want to find a qualify
professional to assess and explore
diagnoses if that's important to you if
you or your partner in a crisis and
uncertain of whether you can maintain
safety reach out for support crisis
hotlines local authorities have a safety
plan that can be done with a therapist
too
can you talk a little bit about there's
a lot of questions about how do I deal
with a narcissist in my life do you have
any advice for what people should do if
they think they have someone like this
in their life and how do you know if you
even can not being a professional like
you
it's a tough one and you're right that's
like a very trendy thing right now
um throwing around this thing if
somebody's a little self-absorbed
selfish there's a difference between
being self-absorbed and being a true
narcissist
um
foreign
I know that we don't have a lot of time
left but I would encourage folks if you
think that this is something that is
affecting your life there is so much
information out there and I really
encourage folks to educate themselves
um knowledge is power but truly if you
are able to educate yourself on
um signs of what a narcissist is or look
into what the traits are then you can
maybe better identify whether somebody
like that is in your life in some cases
it's going to look like you needing to
um seek out self-preservation and maybe
that's placing boundaries as severe as
going no contact if this person has
brought so much harm and it doesn't seem
like they have any intention to try to
repair heal make things better sometimes
it's not as simple as saying not going
to talk to you anymore because this
person may be so intertwined in your
life that that's not an option so if
that's the case like first you just want
to start with educating yourself looking
to what the traits of narcissism are so
you can better understand
and there's actually a lot of support
groups out there for people that are
dealing dealing with managing a
narcissist in their lives especially if
it's a parent yeah yeah sometimes um
that's one of the most difficult
relationships to navigate because
something about it there's like
obligatory stuff sometimes and
um and you often are going to seek and
strive for their love and approval for
the rest of their lives your life it's
going to be inside of us all the time so
um I encourage people to go out there do
some research get into therapy if that's
something that is available and
accessible to you because you're going
to need to be able to have a space that
you can process and referring back to
something that you said is like really
examine and uncover like what is my
stuff what is me and what is out there
because when you start getting better at
identifying what's in here and what's
out there there then you you know make
better and healthier and more active
choices about the things that you can
control and you're better able to let go
of the things that you can't which is
what feeds into worry debilitating
anxiety
um and feeling like you're out of
control of your life speed round so we
can get you out here are we telling our
kids about Santa uh yes I tell my kids
about Santa
um my uh recently my uh stepson said to
my uh daughter uh you know last
Christmas or whatever they were arguing
and he goes um he's 13 she's eight and
he goes he goes you know Santa's not
real right and she goes you know your
dad's not real right
bang
are you responsible for the Santa
presents yes do you do a different
handwriting do you know commit we do we
do
um um I feel very weird about lying to
my kids and every parent is like you're
gonna say that now and you're get in
there and Santa's a way to have
surveillance so that you manipulate your
kid all year you want to get on the
naughty list you're going to need
something you have to you I think like a
white lie I think because it's not about
really lying it's like you're kind of
you want them to believe in like a
higher power too and you it's kind of
like almost like them believing in Santa
is like the it's like uh you know a
little kid building block for them to
you know if you want to be religious for
them to believe in God or for them to
believe in there's something bigger than
us so we're like all connected more
that's how I look at it I'm like I
worship white men exactly yes yes
Santa and and I I mean and listen it's
one of those things where it's like
trade-offs right it's like yes it's a
lie but it makes them so happy that it's
worth it and then eventually they'll
find out that it's not real and that I
don't think that that's a lie that your
children are gonna be like you lied to
me you say it's a tradition and a ritual
yes it's like it's like you just I
personally think I'm big on Santa even
if you're a Jew and then
tooth fairy Easter Bunny Easter Bunny we
don't really care as much about I mean
we get them Easter baskets whatever
Tooth Fairy you better not fuck around
with the tooth fairy if you if you're a
kid puts a tooth under that pillow and
then with inflation now I have to give
my kid a 20. for a last two a twenty
dollar bill I just bet you got four
Bitcoin yeah we'll see how it's done and
then she got a tooth like a like a tooth
that was like gum like it was a candy
piece of candy but it's like in the
shape of a tooth and she put that under
a pillow and we didn't know about it and
no money came and she goes I knew you
guys were the Tooth Fairy she goes she
like made a test and then like once a
kid says she knows it like at eight we
were like yes we are but I said I was
like but you'll still get money for your
teeth just put them under the pillow
okay okay so she said because I'm
worried that I'm gonna have the kid
that's the snitch because I'm gonna be
like it's not real did I I'm just gonna
because I was lied to so much as a kid
and I fucking knew it Santa I knew it
right and I know and I didn't I was like
your lot I didn't like that I was being
that I Knew Too Soon and I guess I felt
like I felt bad saying like I know this
is fake I guess I think that I think
that with with Santa and the Tooth Fairy
and all that do it for eventually the
society will tell like they'll share
some other kids and then they're not
alone right yeah like I'm not
traumatizing because a friend of mine
said uh the kid is five and was like oh
Santa brought these gifts and the kid
had a conniption being like there was a
man in our house right like I thought I
wasn't supposed to talk to strangers how
did he get in right and he like didn't
know how to handle it right yeah I feel
like you know for me it's like um you
know I I want to tell my kids like you
know the truth like yes like when I'll
tell them I'll tell them at the same
time I'd be like okay fine I'll be
honest with you there is no such thing
as Santa but there's also no such thing
as a third gender so
the thing is monogamy yeah exactly you
know I know things are good with your
mom and I now it's good and we're also
in a simulation
yeah when I'm when I'm when I want to
pull the plug on Santa I'm telling her
the truth about everything aliens are
real
out
yeah okay last but religion yes you
doing it yeah so they're in a Catholic
school now nice
um and I know the Catholic school had a
you know black eye we have girls in
there they're fine exactly exactly I
mean I'm not saying they might I know
they said you're supposed to get the HPV
no the hepatitis you're supposed to get
the hepatitis B vaccine okay for babies
boy like and if that's for if you you
can only really get that through gay sex
I was like I don't think we're gonna do
at Catholic school so it should be fine
listen I just think I think you know I
think that you're here
I think the school system at least in
New York my kids go to New York like
public school you know if it works for
you great I like a uniform I like it
wearing the same thing every day exactly
especially that's what Jazz says she's
like you know especially with girls yep
just putting a uniform out for them and
not having to deal with never mind
Catholic schoolgirl uniforms are the
sexiest thing you could wear I know I'm
like can you throw that on babe yeah
yeah and um
and so and so and so uh we like Catholic
school I also just think like there's
you know the smaller class sizes and
it's like I'm not saying whatever
religion you are I I have religion
pounded down my throat China Father Bill
um
I you know like I very Catholic Mother
where there was no other alternative so
I don't want I want my kids to question
if they want to go try Buddhism try
Judaism try you know uh you know Islam
whatever you want to do but I feel like
when I'm when me and her mom are in
charge right now here's the religion we
are yeah so this is the one here's the
structure that we but you you can
deviate from this but at least this some
guidance I don't want them to be like I
don't know anything yeah religion at all
I want like this is the one we tried and
then you from there we tell I tell her
all the time like if you have questions
about Catholicism you can always ask me
ask the priest like there's other
religions you're just too young to know
about them now but you will learn about
them and one of them is called being a
Republican and that's the important one
as long as you're Republican we don't
care yes you will not get an abortion
and so so I like religion I I think that
and again I know that you know people
like it sucks it's a made-up I think
it's again it's like it's like it is
what you do with it you know and I think
as I get older after you know uh I don't
know if you guys noticed but I lost two
parents
um uh I don't bring it up every five
seconds but it really does change your
that's because they got the booster
um no so I uh I feel like this is
something that uh so funny Anthony just
texted me the funniest birthday message
I'm getting all these birthday messages
let me just goes my computer
um and uh
congratulations on getting pregnant I
always pictured he was a mother
but I've got a saying oh uh oh yeah once
you lose parents and have to do funerals
like the way Jewish people run a funeral
dude and then when like the funerals for
my parents were like a disaster it was a
mess it was where and then going to
Saget's funeral that shit was run yeah
like I mean they literally made an
announcement you come up to the casket
do not look at the family of the
deceased do not hug them keep moving you
have three seconds with the casket and
move on like it was so well right
there's a plan in place people bring you
food you grow your beard all the ritual
like it just was the thing is with
Catholicism and Judy it's like
Catholicism you know that's what we are
that's what I was born into and but the
pro you know one of the biggest issues I
have with it and what I what I'm trying
to not pass on to the kids is like you
know that Catholic anxiety that Catholic
guilt because in Catholicism what we do
here on Earth will have implications in
the afterlife if you're not a good
person you're going to hell you're going
to Purgatory doing this or with Judaism
it's like you're when you're dead you're
in the ground it doesn't matter what
there's you're not you're just fucking
in the ground it doesn't matter there's
no implication so like live a good life
and you know be a good person but it's
like don't think because if you you know
I would think like if I masturbated when
I was 13 like my mom would tell me
that's the Angels crying and you're
gonna go go to hell for that or
pre-marital sex so it's like you've
developed this anxiety and this guilt
that that's something that I'm like even
at eight years old on my daughter about
like don't feel guilt by Catholic guilt
like you know she even said she's like
oh you know the the teacher said if we
don't go to church on Sunday like that's
not good I'm like you have your own
relationship with God like if you don't
just because you're going to church
doesn't make you a better or worse
Catholic they'll tell you that it is
because they want you in church to give
money to the church but you have your
own relationship with God I like the
other parameters of Catholicism I like
you know learning about religion and and
I like having a discipline to follow I
think that's you know yeah important but
like don't let this guilt like subside
you know just paralyze you with with
fear last question because that that
that's the kind of shit that I I'm
pretty conflict diverse in most
situations but I know with with animals
I know with a kid I'm gonna be that to
me is like we gotta go down to the
school and talk to the teacher right
that how do you know when yeah you know
I don't want to be one of those parents
that's constantly meddling it's like
they just like let the school do what
they do and then you can have a
conversation at home but are you ever
like I gotta I gotta go talk to the
teacher about this I also when kids I
hear kids like getting bullied I'd be
like I would go to the school and pinch
a kid yeah it's well the thing is too
it's it's definitely a little bit me but
like with Jasmine it's you know she's
the kind of mom where it's like it's
just always in protection of her
children right or wrong which is is I
think more positive than negative
there's some negative with it but like
the teachers called you know the Delilah
was getting into some trouble on the bus
and you know most parents you know when
the principal calls and it's like your
daughter is doing this doing that like
okay how can we work together whatever
and Jasmine's response was what are
these kids doing to my daughter that's
PR that's making her have to be reactive
Defenders have you ever thought about
that and she was like just talking to
the principal like that where she was
like maybe it's these other little kids
around my kid who are making her act
that way and it was like and I think the
prince will realize real quick like I'm
not going to be able to push this lady
around so you know they're like okay
well you know we'll just separate the
kids on the bus yeah that's what my jazz
is like yeah just put my daughter in the
front of the bus where she belongs
because she's a fucking leader I like
these other little stop putting her back
was a park exactly yeah my daughter's
not black she's Puerto Rican
um I know it's the same two people but
um and and and so and so I think like
you know for me though I I know you know
like we have we're we we're gonna we
have kids that aren't their parents like
me and you being Comics other parents
might be like you know we're weird like
we're the weird family because like Dad
Daddy's got a bit of a strange job like
you know my daughter will say that like
you know everybody else's dad it's like
in finance or a cop or a fireman and
like you are do something like a little
bit weirder and I'm like well you know
so but she said to me she's like does
that make me weird then and I was like
no I think it makes you unique I think
and so we don't want to stifle that like
I don't want to know it makes you rich
yeah yeah yeah it's great and then it's
like I don't want to stifle her
creativity
um so and but I think sometimes in
school with like our formal education
system it's designed a little bit to
sometimes like stifle kids creativity
because it's much safer from my daughter
just think like well you know I gotta
stay in line I gotta get good grades I
gotta go to school I gotta follow the
simple plan because then you know I
gotta grow up to be a nurse it's like go
be a nurse I like being a nurse but it's
like if that ain't for you and you know
I have no I don't I'm not I'm not
mandating my child go to college like if
she wants to we have the money saved
that's a trick but she doesn't
absolutely have to do it that's up to
her because for me I'm like the the cost
of college you know it's like to get
into like how annoying do you want her
to be isn't it right it's like I I don't
I don't need yet another fucking
feminist you know and you know as Seneca
said the great philosopher you never
step in the same river twice why do I
have to hear about the stoics all of a
sudden why are mail podcaster High
performing podcasters getting millions
of views of quoting men from 2 000 years
ago I know it used to be stoic sad like
is that I'd literally rather listen to
Andrew Tate
is interesting it's like never step in
the same river twice what does that even
mean yeah Angie who's the he's the
father
um imagine the guy makes some points
yeah I um no I I don't know why I think
it's for me it's because I like like I'm
all about like you know the new age
philosophers but it's like their the
advice from the stoics like tooth out if
it's been trial you know uh tested for
two thousand years and it still holds up
I'm like I like that but it is true
that's good hold up I mean it depends on
who if you're an immigrant trying to get
in America step in the same river twice
yeah exactly I mean that's exactly what
you need to do yeah try and climb that
wall yet again I just feel like they're
so vague that everyone can project on to
it yeah well that's true too I think you
got to do you know whatever it is to you
but yeah it used to be like MMA and now
it's stoicism I love like watching Men
discover things women have known for
thousands of years I know I'll tell Jazz
like I'll read something from Like A
Book Like The Daily stoic like a Ryan
holiday and she'd be like yeah I've
known that since I'm 12. I love that
like if a man has any good advice and
takes a picture on a private plane he
just immediately has 2.5 million
followers in a giant podcast it's just
like I mean and I'm like talking about
my feelings everyone's like Wendy's
crazy Dax Shepard here's 80 million
dollars yeah okay guys so just keep
doing the damn thing I love you new
podcast look at oh well no not new new
no it's Chrissy chaos yeah you have a
new one I got hey babe I got hey babe
podcast and then this is Chrissy chaos
that this is out uh every Monday
um at uh like 7 A.M eastern time yeah
and this is um yeah I got a new set then
I got a new set you haven't looked at
your Instagram but I was like okay this
is
and then we got these podcasts and stand
up christycomedy.com I got um
Big Show bigger shows of My Life coming
up September 22nd 23rd Radio City Music
Hall and theater at MSG yes yeah bitch
and I'll be doing a pregnant special at
the comedy
come come see Whitney's swollen feet on
stage
come let me suck your dick so I can get
this thing out of my body I love you
guys
[Music]
[Applause]